starting off this hour is going to be
Brandon in Maryland hi Brandon welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show I would leave
are you better than I deserve sir what's
up so my wife and I were debt-free and
who seemed to be on opposite side
without having a credit card we
typically after our bills are paid each
month have a surplus of about $4,000 and
we save every month like she likes to
use a credit card I have cut mine up I
can't get her on board and I'm just
trying to figure out what I can do maybe
you have an opinion on how I can go
about talking to her about it why does
she want a credit card I don't know but
I tend I believe that after reading your
book of course that it's so mental that
if you have a credit card even if you
have the cash to pay off each month that
you're going to spend more I'm like if
you actually had cash in your hand or
you were using their debit card but I
guess you're just not seeing my side of
it well I mean you're it's not your side
of it what you just declared were actual
facts so it's not just your side but
that doesn't matter I mean the question
is why does she want a credit card if a
debit card will do everything a credit
card will do why does she want a credit
card yeah it's a reasonable question
yeah and if I give you a debit card and
you're able to do exact same things
you're able to do with your credit card
our budget operates exactly the same way
there's no limitations put on you that
you didn't already have on you by the
two of us working together what is the
objection with the credit card and I
guess you need to find that out because
what I'm Esther is you're just stabbing
in the wind and you don't know whether
you're you don't know what you're aiming
at here so you need to find out why it
is she feels like she needs a credit
card because my guess is that she
probably has some bad information
yes and I think her mother has told you
that you should lower the amount on the
credit card it wouldn't be such a big
deal so if we lower it from what it sat
down to something about five hundred
dollars in less then I don't really care
what her mother thinks her mother's
obviously a fool okay that's not the
issue the issue is look at your wife the
lady that you're married to and say if
you had a debit card that did the exact
same things that a credit card would do
what is the problem with that right you
know hopefully I can talk to you the
future and give you an answer yeah and I
think I think you can give her an answer
then because she's going to say oh I
want the airline miles which is a bogus
argument because seventy-eight percent
of the airline miles are never redeemed
if you do I don't want to try to redeem
them you end up sitting on the wing and
you go through 73 cities to get to one
location you will find out how badly
you've gotten screwed by that great lie
or I've heard the credit card is not as
safe as the debit card is not as safe as
the credit card another lie because if
you actually look on Visa and on
mastercards website they have what's
called a zero liability promise to you
in the event of fraud or theft with the
use of your debit card or your credit
card you have the exact same coverage
you are not liable for people misusing
stealing your identity fraudulently
using your dot your card you have the
exact same coverage there ah I can't
figure out a reason to use one so
consequently you don't have one I don't
have one and you do spend less with a
debit card but you spend even less when
you use cash now I personally use both I
have always got several hundred dollars
in my pocket in cash I'm an old redneck
I like having two or three hundred bucks
in my pocket and no matter where I am
then I've always got a couple debit
cards one on my business and
one on my personal account and there's
money in those accounts and I travel
more than any two of you put together
both for pleasure and for business and I
really don't run into substantial issues
with a debit card that are different
than you run into with the credit card
so I mean they all get you have to toss
all of them every so often now with the
ID theft algorithms your banks like it's
going to reissue these things pretty
consistently whether they're debit or
credit but you're not liable in the
event of fraud and you know you do
actually spend a little bit less the
studies tell us with the debit card
because you understand you're actually
using money out of your own freakin
account and so you do have to stop and
think about it a little bit unless you
have you know unless you got a hundred
thousand bucks in your freaking checking
account you have to stop and think when
you're spending five grand you know so
you really there's a thought has to go
through this process so I hope that
helps